okay so my
opponent is now is jonas d from
from germany 2400 we're gonna get a
three-minute game
and i'm continuing with the with the a6
lines here
can my opponents either
i don't know if they're not watching the
stream but uh
they're not getting the memo that you
gotta
you gotta play play cd5 in these lines
otherwise
this stuff is gonna come and uh
you're usually gonna be in some trouble
now this is in one way
better than what my
opponent had in that other game because
the bishop is well developed on g5
in front of the pawn on on e3
but the disadvantage to that is that now
i have this other
opportunity which i'm going to go for
i'm not actually sure if it's any good
um but basically here i was just gonna
sack an exchange
after ab5 um cb5 knight b5 ab5 rook a8
bishop b4 check followed by bishop b7
and he would either have to go king
e2 or block the check with knight d2
both of them would make his development
very difficult
uh he just chooses to play um
for compensation instead uh
unfortunately
i don't think there is a lot of
compensation
usually in these positions black just
gets to
develop and then consolidate
the the extra pawn
uh yeah e4 i think h6 is useful
to to insert um
when i do castle later on
it's nice not to have to worry about
a knight e4 and then knight g5 coming so
just inserting h6 is very useful
um it probably should go e5 here at some
point
in order to get some some attack
um you know what i think now that he's
waited so long to go e5
oh this is no good um but also after
knight b1
c5 i think i was i was doing
um doing great there
um attacking e4 and
sort of breaking up his center may have
had to give back the pawn but i think i
would have
had the better position regardless
now obviously i just went with a piece
um yeah a clearing night and
and uh there there isn't
a lot of compensation 95 is an excellent
move though
i think
um you know what let's um
let's just complicate the game a little
bit by going c5
i'm hoping for some
[Music]
uh attacks against his rook on on a2 vr
bishop d5
after for instance knight d7 i could
have inserted bishop d5 before i taken
d7
so i think i was doing well there or
obviously i'm doing
well i'm a piece off but i think i might
have been winning
winning even more material um
yeah let's just grab the grab the rook
while you can
it's the same goes knight c6
that's a good move clearly the best
chance
let's um
yeah let's attack his his rook
rook d3 there's bishop c4
with a little secure i think it's called
a skewer
um okay we'll take on d1
and take an h6
this is
unfortunately for him mere
desperation also f5 was good there but i
feel like knight f6 is
sort of cleaner not making the king
unnecessarily
and there we go okay